get a maximum height right
the idea is that you've got some objects
and it is uh let me see
and it's sitting on the surface of the
earth right and you
throw it up at some momentum okay now
maximum height is in terms of velocity
maximum height occurs when the object
has no velocity right because it stops
up there
for a split second okay so in order to
work out a maximum height
that's an x value right
i want to work out when that velocity is
zero and that'll give me an x okay so
let's give this a go
the um
the solution say
they call the maximum height h
okay so that's going to be the
particular x value right
when
x equals h when you get to that maximum
height okay since it's the maximum at
that point you stop
okay so let's take these values pop them
in and see what we get right we get 0
equals
2 g r squared
one over
h right that's where i am where i get
that velocity of zero okay
minus one over r
plus
okay
now what was i after i'm after what that
max height actually is right so it's
actually not that hard i just need to
rewrite a little bit right
let's see here take that v squared over
here
divine through
okay how do i go here
add one over r to both sides right so we
get minus v squared
sorry this is dying
i suppose since this is minus i'll put
this out front
that's my one over r so i've got one
over h
over here okay now since what i want is
h
i'm gonna need to uh take the reciprocal
right so in order to take the reciprocal
i need this to be all one fraction okay
so i guess to combine these my
combination should just be 2g r squared
right so if i make that 2g r squared
i've got to add another 2g
r
at the top
is that okay so far happy
all right so i'm going to get 2 g r
minus v squared all over
2g r squared
that's one on h and now i can flip
so i'm just going to i'm going to cheat
a little bit and just put it here
ah they're all dying on me
okay
there is the maximum height
let's see
eventually something's going to work all
right now
we're almost there so
given some initial velocity however hard
you throw it up okay this is how far
you're gonna get before you come
crashing back down to earth okay
sort off this is something weird going
on here right uh maximum height i would
assume is some positive value yeah some
positive value because you know you
can't well i can't you throw it through
the earth and it goes the other way okay
so therefore
this fraction's a bit interesting right
because what's happening to the whole
thing
as v increases okay well actually let's
start something more basic when v is
equal to zero if i've got my object and
i don't
accelerate it up with any velocity okay
what happens to the whole thing
two g r squared over two g r minus
zero
two g r squared over t r it's just
r right so what that's saying is
if you can't throw at any velocity your
maximum height is
the ground okay the radius of the earth
you don't go anywhere
but as the increases
what's happening
as v gets bigger
this thing starts to get smaller right
because
you've got some number minus a number
which is getting bigger and bigger
bigger so this whole thing is getting
smaller right okay that's good
denominator gets smaller whole thing
gets bigger so that makes sense the
harder you throw it
the bigger this number will be
but not forever right um
if you accelerate this velocity you get
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
it's not as v approaches infinity
okay
because what happens when there's a
particular tipping point i'm interested
in here right we said this height has to
be positive okay
but if you throw hard enough if v is big
enough
v squared will be b bigger than two g r
right assuming you can throw that half
okay
if v squared's bigger what happens to
this whole thing
it becomes negative right what does that
mean
that your maximum height is negative
if your maximum height is negative right
you don't have a maximum height anymore
because what happens is g and r are
insufficient you need more r and more g
to take over for a larger velocity the
thing's just going to go and it's going
to run off forever that's what this
question is about part c okay so they
give us some values
um which are the values that you know we
generally use for approximations because
they do the job we've got a
gravitational
value here 9.8 now that's in meters per
second right
so therefore when i go for radius even
though they tell us it's 6 400
kilometers
i'm going to call it 600 6400
000 meters
i suppose you could have converted into
kilometers if you're lying that remains
6 400 kilometers and this would be
0.0098
kilometers per second okay same deal
doesn't matter which units you use
okay now what do i actually want
right
what's the point at which this fraction
breaks down and explodes and doesn't
actually give us a useful value anymore
um and the answer is it breaks down and
explodes when
two g r minus v squared
is equal to zero that's when the
denominator makes the whole fraction
meaningless okay and of course when you
exceed that
okay that means your velocity is big
enough to take over right and you don't
come back okay
so now i can just solve this okay this
is 2 times 9.8
times
that big number
and that's a negative v squared so i'll
pop it over the other side
okay
now get your calculator out
i think it's like
one two someone help me out like five
five something
who's got it
five
four four yep zero zero zero
okay yep good
okay now that's v squared so take the
square root and i think we should get
this
now what's that mean
um this is in meters per second right
or alternatively if you divide by a
thousand
that's kilometers per second
that's the escape velocity vf that's how
fast you've got to go if you want to
leave the planet right
so uh i really like this because this
this itself you know precisely is the
number that gets quoted okay and you
guys are capable of all of that that
actually makes it work right um you're
not like these players you just have to
look up a book and you're like yeah okay
but why i don't know okay and in fact if
we changed the radius and how strong the
gravity of a planet is right you could
know exactly what the escape velocity is
yeah
so i think that's a really cool result i
hope that made sense the whole way we
went through it and the fact you've got
to be careful what you just sub values
into you can't just pick any equation
okay
all right